ja das 2023 geht sehr rasant und zwar
ziemlich genau so rasant wie wir mit
unserem Planeten Erde durch den Orbit
sausen nämlich mit hunderttausend
Stundenkilometer fliegen wir genau jetzt
durch den Orbit das darf man sich gerne
mal wieder dagegen wertigen dass die
Jahr 2023 hat eine sehr spannende
Dynamik wenn ich jetzt von oben schaue
ich bringe jetzt mal den Blick von oben
ich habe gehört es war noch nie eine
Astrologin in diese Sendung also ich
darf gerne jetzt den Blick erweitern in
die Konstellation von denen wir sprechen
nicht das geht nicht nur politische
Konstellation sondern auch astrologische
Konstellation und wir haben ein ganz
ganz markanten shift der erkennt was in
den Frequenzen und diese shift kommt nur
alle ungefähr 250 Jahre einmal vor das
heißt wir haben hier eine Energie wir
nennen das die Wassermann Frequenz die
sehr viel stärker wird und zwar für den
nächsten 20 Jahre das hat ganz viel zu
tun mit Energien mit Frequenzen die
entdeckt werden was aber man hat mit der
Manifestation des Geistes zu tun mit den
vielen Menschen anfangen sich auch zu
organisieren es ist eine Kraft von wir
nennen es power to the people was wir
eben schon bei der Politik besprochen
hatten es ist nicht mehr so dass die
Menschen sich alles sagen lassen werden
wir hatten vor 500 Jahren das war genau
das Jahr 543 diese Konstellation
ebenfalls und das war der Moment wo
Kopernikus seine Thesen veröffentlichtet
das nicht die der Planet Erde im Zentrum
ist sondern dass die Sonne im Zentrum es
mussten sie vorstellen der hat den Papst
ein vollkommen neues Weltbild offeriert
und dass ich dann auch durchgesetzt hat
und genau und so eine Schwelle sind wir
jetzt auch unsere Weltbilder ändern sich
radikal und das hat mit der totalen
absoluten ganz klaren Digitalisierung zu
tun alles was digitalisiert werden kann
wird digitalisiert und das können wir
gleich näher vertiefen wir haben wenn
wir sie nach diesem Jahr Fragen doch
ganz viele andere Zyklen und eins ist
der wichtigste Monat ist der März und
der April wo wir hinschauen dürften weil
das so Chaos Monate sind da unglaublich
viel Power zusammen sehr viel Wut sehr
viel
Ärger könnte im Feld sein das heißt auch
hier für alle bitte atmen in der Ruhe
bleiben und wir haben dann anschließend
das wird sehr sehr spannend sehr
dynamisch eine Phase wo wir diese neue
Zeit die sogenannte die vernetzende Zeit
das erste Mal so richtig spüren und das
ist auch für Sie natürlich ganz wichtig
in Richtung wie gehen wir oder überhaupt
energetisch weiter das sind die Monate
ab Ende März dann april im Mai und der
juni 2023 wir werden alle geschäftlich
privat politisch gesellschaftlich eine
erste Idee bekommen was es heißt wenn
wir uns richtig vernetzen das hat eine
Schattenseite und eine Lichtseite die
Lichtseite sind die wunderbaren
Möglichkeiten sich neu zu informieren
und vollkommen neue Innovation das ist
das große Thema aus dem Boden zu
stampfen die sind nämlich alle schon da
die haben sich alle schon vorbereitet
die Schattenseite da weiß ich immer
darauf hin auf das Christopher Projekt
beispielsweise wir sind heute in der
Lage in so kleinen
Mikroorganismen uns zu bewegen dass und
die DNA ausschneiden kann und die
genschere scheint mir ist natürlich mit
dem Nobelpreis belegt worden aber mir
scheint dass die genschere etwas ist was
uns absolut total wirklich bewusst sein
muss wir sind heute imstande Menschen zu
klonen und da stelle ich hier die Frage
es gibt noch viele andere Themen aber
ich stelle hier die Frage ist der Mensch
ein Auslaufmodell weil das wichtigste
was jetzt immer wichtiger wird und dass
wir dann ein Zentrum an Zeitraum für den
nächsten 20 Jahre ist dass wir mit der
Ethik dass wir die Ethik ins Feld
bringen und der Digital Ethiker digital
ethikerin wird absolut der Beruf der
Zukunft
ja sie haben da jetzt gerade zugehört
alle haben genickt als wüssten sie auch
alle bescheid
wir haben hier am Tisch Physiker
Journalisten Autoren glauben sie an die
Sterne glauben sie an die Energien
glauben Sie dass es das gibt was uns
zusammenhält
Konstellationen in den fernweiten die
wir hier vielleicht gar nicht so richtig
interpretieren können ich finde das sehr
sympathisch was sie vorgetragen haben
aber ich bin ein sehr hoch rationaler
Mensch bin und ich glaube das ist habe
ich gesagt
einfach öffentlich
auch aber ich glaube dass unsere Zukunft
davon abhängt wie wir uns entscheiden
wie wir handeln wie wir denken alles
Menschen ich glaube nicht dass unsere
Zukunft oder unser Schicksal in den
Sternen
liegt aber ich glaube auch dass wir in
rasanten Zeiten leben man muss nicht ein
Prophet sein um das zu sehen und ich
glaube auch dass die Menschen jetzt zu
wachen gerettet werden
die stehen auf und sagen ich will auch
beteiligt werden ich lasse mich nicht zu
einem Marionette machen der Politik oder
der Medien oder der Weltwirtschaft oder
was auch immer ich will mitmachen wir
leben in Zeiten in einer Zeitenwende und
es wird sich sehr viel verändern ich
befürchte aber dass unsere Politiker
nicht auf der Höhe dieser zeitenwände
sind
das wichtige das Volk steht auf und das
ist dieses andere dat und das ist 1789
wisst ihr alle noch oder wissen Sie alle
noch das war der Moment wo aus der
Monarchie in Frankreich eine Republik
wurde weil die Menschen aufgestanden
sind wir sind genau in dieser Zeit die
Menschen werden wach und ich denke da
machen sie machen wir alle sehr viel
Arbeit im in der Öffentlichkeit zu sagen
hey denkt nach fangt an lasst euch nicht
alles von top-down hatte ich vorhin
gehört top down sagen weil die
Strukturen top-down die werden sich
auslaufen und das wird die Power und die
Information kommt von unten die das Volk
wird anfangen wieder
wieder zu sagen wo es lang geht und dann
noch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt ist
natürlich dass die Art und Weise wie wir
mit dem technologischen Fortschritt
umgehen immer ist immer immer ist was
religiöses dabei zum Beispiel oh äh
jetzt kommt Gentechnik dann der Mensch
ist skeptisch und denkt das wird uns
zerstören das wird dann Jurassic Park
wieder jetzt hier wieder hergestellt äh
oder
[Musik]
künstliche Intelligenz auch da da der
Mensch ist jetzt ein Auslaufmodell nein
der Mensch ist ein wunderbares Wesen und
hat das im Laufe der Geschichte bewiesen
der ist auch ein furchtbares Wesen und
hat so viele Kriege und wie viele Leid
auch aber er hat auch seine Geschichte
gelernt und ist nie richtig wirklich
zurückgegangen sondern der Fortschritt
geht immer nach vorne vor 200 Jahren war
die skalaverei eine ganz normale Sache
heute jeder Mensch auf der Erde fast
jeder Mensch echte die Sklaverei und
akzeptiert so was nicht Frauenrechte
darüber sind wir uns alle einige das
müssen wir nicht noch mal verhandeln
Kinderarbeit all diese Phänomene der
Mensch hat aus seiner Geschichte gelernt
aber mit Zuversicht und migrationalität
hat er die Welt verändert nicht mit
Emotionen und die Füße Aberglaube oder
Irrationalität
ein Thema Astrologie auch ein bisschen
noch tiefer gegangen in das was das
nächste Jahr für uns alle bringen könnte
auch eine Herausforderungen an
Menschlichkeit an das wie sich viele
Menschen vielleicht auch innerlich
verändern wollen was glaubst Du ist
Astrologie überhaupt dein Ding oder
sagst du dir philosophische Diskussion
gerne Sterne keine Ahnung aber leider
eine absolute Realistin das heißt ich
kann damit nicht viel anfangen aber es
ist toll dass das gibt definitiv ich bin
da ein bisschen pessimistischer deswegen
auch was unsere Zukunft betrifft und
muss da wieder dran anknüpfen was Sie
gesagt haben am Anfang der Sendung wo
sie meinten dass wir das Deutschland
wieder oder der Westen der ganze Westen
wieder in einer Art Mittelalter verfällt
und es gab mal eigentlich erst
Kunststoff die Epochen eingeteilt hat
und da drunter Renaissance und dann
kommt wieder der verfallen und ich
glaube wir nehmen so einen Zeitalter des
Verfalls und unsere Politik wird auch
nicht da rauskommen über was wir gerade
geredet haben dieses ideologische und
diese Burg Politik die die Realitäten
nicht anerkennt vor allem mit Islamismus
dass wir Integrationsprobleme haben dass
wir ideologisch an die Energiepolitik
rangeht ich glaube darauf kommen wir
nicht heraus ich glaube eher dass es
auch sich verschlimmern kann und ja das
ist meine pessimistische Sichtweise auf
das ja ehrlich gesagt Sie haben ja zum
Glück noch die optimistische wir haben
ja am Tisch quasi alles vertreten ich
möchte einmal von Ihnen wissen wer sind
denn jetzt in jeder schaut natürlich
auch auf seinen Horoskop viele wollen
sie in der Runde nicht wissen ich bin
Stier lass ich mal so kurz fallen können
wir gleich noch mal nach der Sendung
aber wer sind denn jetzt vielleicht die
großen Gewinner die großen absahne was
sind die Menschen die sagen können 2023
das wird mein Jahr darf ich da schon in
Ihrem Unternehmen
ganz wichtig ich meine ich habe jetzt
einen einen Einsatz hier mal
reingeworfen ja besprechen so viele
unglaublich viele Aspekte mit natürlich
Betrachtungsweise und ein ganz wichtiger
und sehr schöner ist die Zunahme der
spirituellen der spirituellen
Bewusstseins der Menschen wir sehen das
an den vielen vielen Meditationen
weltweit die sind natürlich jetzt auch
durch die Online-Möglichkeiten geht das
ganz anders es geht alles um Frequenzen
wir werden ganz stark
frequenzmedizin entwickeln Frequenz
Heilungen über Frequenzen uns
miteinander austauschen wir werden mit
anderen Frequenzen von anderen Planeten
sprechen werden Energiefelder übrigens
für die nächsten also ich habe den
ganzen spannendes Aspekt spannenden
Aspekt bis 2034 ganz neue Ressourcen mit
atomgesteuerten Raketenantrieb
beispielsweise das sind alles so Themen
die 34 optimistisch aber wir haben
solche
die Ränder sind selbstverständlich ja
die jetzt im Moment gerade mit dem
Glücksplanet im Zeichen Stier ab Mitte
Mai
geborenen Stier heißt aber manifestiere
das Gute Stier hat mit Schönheit zu tun
mit Bewusstsein mit auch mit auch
finanziellen Ressourcen auch denen es
vielleicht finanziert gerade nicht so
gut geht haben wir alle jetzt
Möglichkeiten und das ist spannend wie
es als anfängt zu interagieren wir sind
ja derart vernetzt und vielleicht wäre
es sinnvoll wenn sie sich mal mit der
universellen Verschränkung
auseinandersetzen ist faszinierend wie
alles miteinander auf alle Energieebene
verbunden ist wir ziehen sozusagen in
der einen Ecke vom Universum und den
alles mit ja also ein Mensch das hat die
Philosophie wir mal attacker damals auch
gleich gesagt ein Mensch wenn sich ein
Mensch bewegt bewegt sich das Ganze
Universität Doktor peter ist für Sie als
Physiker sie sitzen nebeneinander ich
sehe sie aber dicken und sie
beschafft beschäftigen sich ja mit den
Zahlen sie von auch von und jetzt hört
sie Energie und all dies und mit was man
sich beschäftigt
sie innerlich den Kopf oder haben sie
dafür eine ja ein Herz ein Sinn als Mann
der Wissenschaft weiß ich natürlich dass
alle großen Astronomen ihr Geld
hauptsächlich mit Astrologie verdient
haben das kann ich nicht ganz negieren
also auch der genannte Kopernikus die U3
und visuelle heißen das war damals so
also vielleicht ist er da was dahinter
es ist außerdem so dass das
naturwissenschaftliche Weltbild ist ein
geschlossenes es beantwortet die oder es
ist erstmal es ist dafür da neue Fragen
zu stellen aber wenn neue Fragen
gestellt werden dann entwickelt man
Methoden um innerhalb eines
geschlossenen Systems diese Fragen zu
beantworten und ähm die Verschränkung
von Elementarteilchen ist zum Beispiel
jetzt also mittlerweile eine Banalität
gab auch eine Nobelpreis für den für den
Zeilinger aber was ist jetzt wirklich
bewegt auf auf
universeller Ebene das kann könnte ihn
kein Physiker ehrlich sagen wenn er
redlich ist
also das sind einfach Erkenntnisgrenzen
wo die Physik ein Grenzen stößt aber als
Mensch und auch ein bisschen als Christ
und
finde ich das sehr unterstützenswert
weil sie sagen ich beobachte das nämlich
auch dass im Moment sehr vieles im Fluss
sind dass auch dass man viel mehr ins
Gespräch kommt als noch vom halben Jahr
mit Menschen aus dem ganz anderen
politischen Lager weil die alle irgendwo
die Nase voll haben von diese
langweiligen intellektuell an öden denn
ähm Debatte in der eigenen Blase das ist
diese Selbstverstärkung das ist doch
nicht interessant und da ist sehr viel
Offenheit da und ähm es ist sehr viel
auch Wille da ähm zum Kern zu gehen und
wieder wieder auf den also die die
Fragen wirklich zu lösen und was wir
jetzt da sind also diese Nachwirkungen
die Grünen sind heute zu sein die
Spießer von damals als ich klein war was
die CDU aber heute sind richtig die die
die geistig stehen gebliebenen die dann
in lützerath irgendwie so winzig kleine
Forderungen stellen die völlig daneben
sind und also einen echten Problem
wirklich völlig Vorbeigehen tut mir leid
für die aber ich finde das nicht
besonders interessant man muss dann auch
nicht mit denen irgendwie in einer
Talkshow drüber reden unbedingt und da
sehe ich eben halt tatsächlich Chance
auch also im chinesischen ist es glaube
ich das Chance und Krise ist so das
gleiche Schriftzeichen irgendwie sowas
und das das ist halt auch eine Wahrheit
also in solchen Zeiten wo alles zur
Disposition steht werden die Leute sich
müssen sie werden gezwungen wieder
Verantwortung für sich selber zu
übernehmen und das ist im übrigen unsere
Mutter auch von Deutschland
Arbeitgeberverband ich trage die
Verantwortung für mein Leben Punkt und
das ist sehr sympathisch von Ludwig er
hat aus der aus der denke ähm und das
ist eben die Chance die in diesem Jahr
auch da steht die diese Krisenzeit die
selbst verschuldet ist deswegen betone
ich das auch immer so diese Energiekrise
ist zu 100% hausgemacht da gibt es
keinen sehr russische Einmarsch hat es
verstärkt aber nicht nicht bewirkt und
das muss man wer das verstanden hat
macht sich selbst Gedanken enable sich
selbst also ermächtigt sich selbst
Entscheidungen zu treffen und das macht
mir dann doch ein bisschen Hoffnung ja
und ich muss also wirklich noch ergänzen
also es ist das eine ich bin
verantwortlich für mich selbst das ist
absolutes total zentrale und das hat uns
die mikrop-krise auch gelernt und das
andere ist aber auch das Kollektiv ja
dass wir im Kollektiv auch in den
Gruppen wirklich wichtig auf
Verantwortung übernehmen sollten
füreinander und das ist nicht das man
gegen etwas schießt wie jetzt ihr wisst
diskutiert haben heute mehrheitlich
sondern dass man miteinander sich
organisiert und das Wichtige ist wir
sind dann an der Schwelle ich betone ist
noch mal von einem vollkommen neuen
Weltbild was ich öffnen wird sind das
alles Geburtswehen in den wir stecken
wir sind wir haben einfach den Joker
gezogen dass wir jetzt hier inkarniert
sind und dieses diese Themen in die Welt
bringen dass wir mit den ganzen
Netzwerken die entstehen und den vielen
Parallelgesellschaften übrigens
Kreislaufwirtschaft ist ein ganz
wichtiges Stichwort ganz viele Menschen
die sind nicht laut die hört man gar
nicht sind im organisieren sich selber
unabhängig zu machen von dem was die
Politiker sagen und nur so ganz am Rande
noch von wegen Thema wir haben einen
ganz wichtigen shift jetzt dieses Jahr
im Sommer das ist der Juli 2023 da geht
ein neues Thema los für die nächsten
anderthalb Jahre und das ist die
widderenergie und widder sind die
Pioniere bitte ist die Energie für uns
alle gilt das sind diejenigen die
gefordert sind vorauszugehen sie und sie
machen das ja alle schon aber das in der
Allgemeinheit Menschen anfangen sich so
zu organisieren miteinander in diesem
Netzwerken wo wir null Ahnung haben wo
wir nachher landen in der Physik nennt
sich das tatsächlich Selbstorganisation
von Systemen hin zu komplexeren Systemen
und das das einzige was man dafür
braucht ist billige Energie und da ist
haben wir mit energiepolitischen kleines
Problemchen aber wir kriegen das hin
okay
einfach kein Problem
das Thema Zeit haben nur ganz ganz kurz
das Thema Energie ist natürlich das Mega
Thema und Energie kommt natürlich von
innen ist klar aber wir werden so viele
neue Energiequellen entwickeln und
entdecken die wir noch gar nicht kennen
also ich bin absolut total überzeugt wir
werden in den nächsten drei vier Jahren
und in acht und die Jahre 2025 26 27
stehen wir komplett waren das mit all
diesen Erfindungen die jetzt da sind die
aus dem Boden stampfen Seins nur mal
leuchtende Bäume ja mit mit ganz viel
Möglichkeiten Energie anders zu
generieren insbesondere sich auch die
große Sonne also das finde riesen Thema
wir sind an einer vollkommen neuen
umdenke und ich bin total
entspannt und beruhigt auch mit Blick
auf dieses Jahr aber es ist sehr an ich
bin verhalten optimistisch ich glaube
dass der Mensch zu Freiheit und zum
Fortschritt verdammt ist das muss er
aber damit da weiterhin die sind
Fortschritt gestalten kann muss er
rational bleiben und sich vom
deterministischen denken Ablösen von
diesen religiösen Schema Gut und Böse
Sünde und Hölle und
Wahrheit und absolut falsch und man muss
sich von diesem Schema befreien und man
muss auch den Konflikt wagen und
sich sich stellen wir können nicht alles
irgendwie harmonisch betrachten die
Demokratie ist nicht harmonisch das
Leben ist nicht harmonisch die Natur ist
nicht so harmonisch wie wir denken alles
Gerd und steht ineinander Zukunft wir
müssen diesen Konflikt Wagen und uns
diesen Konflikt stellen und miteinander
offen klar reden damit wir weiterkommen
können da gibt es immer zwei Aspekte
eine Aspekt ist der kriegerische oder
andere ist der friedliche das sind diese
zwei großen Kraftströme auf diesem und
alles geht nur miteinander und ich
glaube darauf haben wir uns an diesem
Tisch hier heute Abend auch geeinigt
dass wir das alle zusammen schön dass
Sie alle hier waren hier liegt noch ihr
Buch hätten Sie es gerne in die Kamera
morgen glaube ich dürfen alle
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zur Party
kommen glaube ich schon so gesagt ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
Gästen ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei Ihnen fürs zuschauen morgen sehen
wir uns wieder bei Villach 8 bis